what's going on and reject nation it's
Greg Alba here John so we got word from
Rosa Parra over at patreon one of our
top pledges over there she wanted to
know our thoughts on something I didn't
hear about till I read her message and I
was like what the hell are you talking
about apparently there's a new Star Wars
film series separate from Rian Johnson's
trilogy that's gonna be created by the
people who created the game of Thrones
show that is David Benioff and DB Weiss
so this is pretty exciting news in in
certain ways I already feel like people
already feeling like there's so much
Star Wars already getting a new TV show
already another planned trilogy that
Rian Johnson's doing we still need to
wrap up the new Skywalker Sokka don't
forget all those spin-offs and all the
spin-offs that we're doing too so
there's so much Star Wars happening
right now these creators I love Game of
Thrones I think Game of Thrones is a
great show I guess my only concern with
these guys doing it is that the realm in
which they've created has been from a TV
show format where they've had a long
time to really explore characters really
get time to really build everything and
I'm thinking about the latest season a
game of Thrones or not people have been
responding I personally love the latest
season in Game of Thrones and I know
there's a big part of the fan base that
felt that it was a little rushed a
little compact because they had less
episodes than they normally are allowed
to so I'm thinking man if they already
had that issue with having less episodes
might be a little challenging for them
with having just movie format to tell a
story from with brand new characters
well that and they don't have any more
book to draw from of the source material
and I know some fans have been kind of
upset with them over their handling of
the post source material episodes and
stuff like that you know going into a
Star Wars trilogy I mean the stuff
they've had to conquer on Game of
Thrones is certainly stuff they can use
there they work with a massive ensemble
and a whole lot of worlds and a whole
lot of designs and a whole lot of
massive production values I have no
doubt that they can handle the project
yes magnitude and as a fan of Game of
Thrones the TV show with that little
minor concern I have because I don't
feel that same way how a lot of people
have thoughts about the latest season I
of the show so I think these guys who
can create these epic fantasies that are
very character-driven and also bring
some awesome action sequences to the
plate
I think it's cool for them to switch
fantasy genres into sci-fi fantasy with
exploring the Star Wars territory I'm
glad it's not part of the Skywalker saga
that they get a chance to create their
own brand new thing I probably a little
more excited if they could be a little
more than r-rated size because Game of
Thrones is pretty hard our show in terms
of character exploration setting up
interesting enticing characters
exploring fantasy I think these guys are
the perfect fit what I have liked a
woman to have come on board for Star
Wars sure that would have been cool cuz
yeah because you know that's what fans
have been wanting is for Star Wars to
start getting away from white man
directly Star Wars villains and now we
got two new white guys a new trilogy on
the heels of some of the complaints I've
heard about season six I will say that
they're perhaps better suited to his
Star Wars because Game of Thrones you
expect a certain amount of like
political intrigue and the the
back-and-forth between houses and
nations and there's lots of things to
talk about whereas I feel like the
difference they split with the season
six could actually lend itself really
well to Star Wars there's a lot more
spectacle there and there's a lot more
action and I think you can go more bold
with this like if this was them taking
up Episode nine I'd be a little
concerned because you know Rian Johnson
made some pretty bold choices in which
is something we would want is like
someone who's gonna make bold daring
choices and these creators are known to
do that with their own TV show but if
you do that with the Skywalker saga
specifically that obviously upsets a lot
of fans the fact that this is separate
from that leaves room to do something
that is really bold and really different
I hope they don't get fired 90% way
through the production of this film I
hope they're able to do something bold
and different because it just says all
the superhero movies of Nina that Star
Wars will - I mean between having an
episode 9 a Rian Johnson sure ology and
in this trilogy and then you know the
other spin-offs that they plan on doing
I would say that between all those
different Star Wars films to choose from
this is probably the one on most
intrigued by at the current moment it's
the biggest question mark for me I guess
the one I'm most interested by is the
Rian Johnson
but this does seem like a neat idea and
to hear somebody else's take on stars is
always something I'm open to let's hope
we don't get sick of Star Wars a few
years from now people huh some people
are already sick and also Rosa Parra
thank you so much for keeping us up we
know you're the biggest fan you are the
lady Stark of our patreon page yeah I
know you sent us a message saying you're
sending us a gift in the mail and I'm
like man you're one of our highest
pledges you don't have to do that we
will take the gift though I love gifts
gifts are my favorite thing in Barbie it
from us to dejected generosity if I know
you the gift is primarily gonna be for
Jon's usage and it's probably not gonna
be anything for me since I know you love
Jon way more than me hey I'll share with
you yeah you could share the fleshly
alright guys well what do you guys think
of this news you excited for it do you
hate it
are you sick of Star Wars do you want
more Star Wars can we get to a point
where we get a Star Wars movie every two
months every week you can subscribe to
the real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and check us out on
patreon a lot of exclusive different
kinds of videos over there